ich bin ja
psychotraumatologie und damit stress
expertin und wir untersuchen den stress
den kinder jugendliche erwachsene haben
und gucken wie wie können wir was können
wir mit denen tun damit sie besser
werden die brauchen drei sachen brauchen
auch erwachsene die müssen dass die
müssen soziale mitmenschlichkeit erleben
das heißt da muss verlässlich jemand für
sie da sein wenn sie in not sind dann
kommen wir mal gucken was jetzt über die
politik dazu macht das zweite ist sie
müssen sich in sicherheit führen können
die dürfen nicht das gefühl haben dass
es schlimm ist und immer schlimmer wird
und das dritte ist sie müssen sich aus
der geschichte ziehen können das heißt
warum passieren die dinge was ist schief
was läuft schief das heißt sie müssen
kritik üben dürfen
und das muss auch breit diskutiert
werden und in allen drei bereichen ist
die politik und sind die medien
reingegangen und haben genau das
gegenteil gemacht sie machen den leuten
angst sie machen das gefühl von
unsicherheit sie geben denen identitäts
unsicherheiten ich muss auf dieses
gender ding jetzt heute nicht eingehen
könnten auch mein blutdruck steigern ja
und sie sie geben den leuten keinen sinn
wenn wenn politik in der lage ist zu
sagen
liebe leute wir machen fehler wir müssen
die korrigieren wir haben jetzt ein
großes drama auch was unsere
energieversorgung angeht
wir müssen zusammen überlegen wie wir
das lösen können man muss eine breite
diskussion in der mitte der gesellschaft
haben sonst hat man daher in der
opposition aus weigel und wagenknecht
und in der mitte ist es voll okay jetzt
ja nun auch frau war schon jemand soll
ja einen reden hier ja die die
unbedingt das also auch die afg so
geächtet wird finde ich nicht in ordnung
geht so wenn die cdu sich da nicht
diesen teil abgeschnitten hätte sie auch
gar nicht gegeben so also wichtig ist zu
sagen man kann aber nicht den äußersten
rändern sozusagen
es muss in der mitte der gesellschaft
diskutiert werden und was kinder und
jugendliche und auch erwachsene brauchen
ist eine breite diskussion die kritik
muss auf den tisch und sie muss breit
auf den tisch das heißt es bleibt kein
stein auf dem anderen so gewinnt man
kinder jugendliche und auch erwachsene
indem man sie beteiligt und sagt lasst
uns lösungen finden die situation sieht
so und so und so aus das passiert aber
nicht stattdessen wird immer rigoroser
als wären das strafende eltern ja von
oben und nach unten was wir dürfen was
wir nicht dürfen das verunsichert gerade
kinder und jugendliche enorm aber sie
haben eben auch gesagt die medien würden
versagen sie sind hier bei dem größten
mädchen aus europas interessiert mich
natürlich ihre kritik an meiner zukunft
im journalismus ja das ist eine kritik
die auch berechtigt ist glaube ich denn
die medien leben davon ich war ja weiß
wahrscheinlich kein ich war früher mal
selber wissenschaftsjournalistin jahr
zehn jahre meines lebens es ist
interessant zu sehen dass medien nur
noch so stotz von da ist eine
katastrophe das war schlimmes passiert
und da und da und da und wenn dann
politik und medien zusammen spielen und
wenn viele medien dies die sendung hier
ist eine löbliche ausnahme ja also wir
sehen in der öffentlich-rechtlichen
wie regierungstreu die sind jetzt gibt
es endlich eine diskussion darüber wie
mehr zeit auch gestern hart ausgeteilt
bei markus lanz dem bereich sehr
erstaunt dass er märz das so
angesprochenen sabbat für zeit
allerhöchste zeit dass endlich sozusagen
mehr breiter diskutiert wird in den
öffentlich rechtlichen sind die meisten
volontäre das weiß man
den grünen und den linken und viele
dieser arbeiten
sind ab und zu
kleine offener diskutiert haben wenn sie
sich eins aussuchen können das elend von
kindern jugendlichen das ist das was die
meisten menschen erreicht dass die
kinder verzweifelt sind das so viele
kinder zusammenbrechen dass man ja zu
gibt es sehr viele artikel da muss ich
auch mal die kollegen im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk in schutz nehmen
ich finde das thema ist vor allem auch
in den letzten monaten sehr breit
vielleicht fragen wir da auch meine
segelclubs genug aufmerksamkeit bekommt
aber da habe ich einige berichte zu
gelesen na ja es geht ja nicht um die
berichte selbst wenn wir das jetzt als
thema nehme ist es wieder ein negatives
ja genau das zu deutlich anderen haben
ist das was unseren kindern fehlt und
das sind verlässliche ansprechen und die
haben sie nicht die haben sie es gibt
keine vertrauenspersonen mehr in den
schulen da wechseln die lehrer alle zwei
drei jahre in den klassen das heißt das
kind hat gar keinen gegenüber mir die
politik investiert in projekte dann
macht einen träger ein projektantrag und
er kriegt er den genehmigt und nicht
nachhaltig in die organisation unsere
stärke oder muss ich uns ein bisschen
loben ist wir arbeiten auch beziehung
liebe nachhaltigkeit das heißt teilweise
meine mitarbeiter arbeiten schon seit
zehn zwölf jahren am gleichen kind das
heißt bei uns kommen kinder im alter von
vier fünf sechs jahren in die
einrichtung und die mitarbeiter und
begleitet von den mitarbeitern bis hin
in die berufsausbildung das gibt kaum
eine organisation in deutschland wo das
genau so ist weil man immer nur projekte
gefördert bekommt wir brauchen
verlässliche vertrauensperson an den
schulen wo die kinder sind um sie zu
stärken zu motivieren wo man eben auch
die psychischen probleme feststellen
kann was der lehrer nicht kann weil der
lehrer hat jetzt 25 schüler davor sind
im ballungsgebiet 23 verhaltensauffällig
oder falls kreativ das kann ja gar nicht
lösen aber menschen die sich in die
kinder investieren
die ihre potenziale erkennen ihre
potenziale fördern sie in
sozialkompetenz zu sprechen sie
unterstützen mit vielen verschiedenen
möglichkeiten das fehlt und solche
nachrichten brauchen wir und solche
projekte brauchen wir die vorgestellt
börse ihr wunsch ist zusammengefasst ist
man über die positiven projekte mehr
berichtet und nicht nur die negativen
erklärt werden kann wenn dieses kind
gefördert werden und bereit ist sich
fördern zu lassen darüber berichten
häufig noch eine sache sagen die haben
wir brauchen so etwas wie case
management überall weil wir sehen dass
an allen ecken und enden leute
wegbrechen und wenn die gesagt kriegen
rufen sie doch da mal an und da mal an
dann rufen die einmal daran dann kriegen
sie gesagt ein therapieplatz könnte
vergessen in einem jahr vielleicht oder
in zwei jahren dann bleiben die zu hause
und dann wird es schlimmer und schlimmer
und wir wissen dass es komisch dann
könnten wir jetzt noch das fass
aufmachen das ja auch die
psychotherapeutin ausbildung in
deutschland sehr gosch billig ist